movie villains often look monstrously
inhuman but in general the actors who
play them are in fact bonafide human
beings
let's take a look behind all of the
makeup and prosthetics to get a good
view of the folks who bring those
baddies to life
danny devito makes a great villain
though in our hearts he's absolutely
anything but he unforgettably
demonstrated his penchant for evil in
1992's batman returns in which he played
classic batman foe the penguin his real
name is oswald cobblepot which
sounds a bit like a fake name that
devito's it's always sunny in
philadelphia character frank reynolds
might come up with devito is a pretty
physically distinct individual
so plenty of his fans probably
recognized him in batman returns even
underneath all the makeup
but the criminal gang leader who's
raised by a family of sewer penguins
doesn't really look anything like the
actor we know and love
designing the character involved
experimenting with multiple nose shapes
and many different makeup hues
in the end devito's face was painted a
pasty white his teeth were made to look
rotten
and his eyes were heavily shadowed and
most disgustingly of all the penguin
drools black saliva
it was just kind of ooze out you know
and dripped down
believe it or not actor doug jones's
eyes aren't really located in the palms
of his hands like how they are when he
plays the pale man in the 2006 fantasy
film pan's labyrinth
in real life his bodily features are
where you'd expect them to be
except when he's utilizing his
contortionist skills but on screen he
can often be seen playing otherworldly
creatures
if you're a film buff you've probably
seen plenty of his work but chances are
you wouldn't recognize him on the street
as his roles nearly always require heavy
makeup and prosthetics
jones is a very lean six foot three
inches tall which makes him perfect for
a wide variety of non-human roles
like billy and hocus pocus or the
amphibian man in the shape of water
it's fitting and unsurprising then that
he collaborates often with director
guillermo del toro who's known for his
distinct and elaborate visuals del toro
directed pan's labyrinth in which jones
played both the pale man
and the fawn in real life jones is a
genial man who describes himself as
a died in the wool christian from the
midwest adorably he recently recreated
his engagement photo with his college
sweetheart
turned wife on their 35th anniversary
and posted the result on twitter
hugo weaving is so unrecognizable as the
red skull in captain america the first
avenger that some fans might not have
even noticed that he was replaced by
another actor in avengers infinity war
and end game the new red skull was
brought to life by ross marquin
in a part largely created with cgi
things were a lot more physical for
weaving as he sat in the makeup chair
for hours on set while the design team
worked their magic with seven
pieces of overlapping silicone the
difference between these two red skulls
is actually what led to weaving turning
down the opportunity to return to the
role
as he revealed the timeout in 2020
marvel backed away from the contracts
that they'd originally agreed upon by
attempting to pay
weaving less for the new movies than for
the first avenger
weaving recounted they said it's just a
voice job it's not a big deal i actually
found negotiating with them through my
agent
impossible and i didn't really want to
do it that much but i would have done it
while you probably won't see weaving in
any future avengers films you can
certainly see him in plenty of other
high-profile movies he played the
revolutionary masked main character in v
for vendetta and his real face became
easily recognizable after he played
agent smith in the matrix movies
and elrond and the lord of the rings
trilogy jim carrey's notoriously
expressive face can render him
unrecognizable from one moment to the
next the versatile actor has played many
roles that have utilized his chameleonic
nature
he was cartoonishly transformed for
1994's the mask he sported bright red
hair and a green mask as the riddler in
1995's batman and forever and then in
2000 he wore
head-to-toe green fur in how the grinch
stole christmas you might call
all of those roles a series of fortunate
events as they made carrie famous and
earned him plenty of dough but the
coincidences that plagued the baudelaire
siblings in 2004's lemony snickets a
series of unfortunate events in which
carrie played count
olaf aren't nearly so whimsical
portraying olaf was no walk in the park
either as carrie reportedly had to spend
three hours in the makeup chair each day
to play the villain who stalks and
tortures the baudelaires but it wasn't
all bad as he's admitted that he had a
quote
childlike fascination with the
transformational powers of makeup that
he experienced in that film
it's safe to say that his fans share the
fascination and love him no matter what
form his features take
villainy and makeup go hand in hand with
horror movie clowns as demonstrated
clearly by pennywise
the terrifying jester played by bill
skarsgard in both 2017's it
and 2019's it chapter 2. the swedish
actor got into his clown makeup early
asking his girlfriend to prepare his
face for an audition that just required
some simple white face
of course he ultimately landed the role
and fully transformed into the pennywise
we know and fear but skarsgard's real
transformation occurred on the inside
he's called pennywise his most
exhausting role
ever on both a physical and
psychological level and he wasn't even
talking about the two and a half hours
it took to complete the look the part
required an enormous amount of energy
from the actor and he also had to deal
with the fact that his performance made
at least one child actor cry
real tears how feast on your flesh as i
feed on your fear skarsgard comes from a
family of actors all of them quite
handsome
his father stellan has also been
physically transformed for roles like
bootstrap bill turner and the pirates of
the caribbean films it's a testimony to
the power of makeup that you'd never
look at pennywise and the barnacle-faced
bill and realize they're actually father
and son
darth maul the vermillion villain from
the star wars universe was played by ray
park
a martial artist and actor who got his
start as a stunt double in 1997's mortal
kombat annihilation
since then he's appeared in a number of
action-oriented parts with maul being
the most famous
park loved playing him one reason being
that becoming the character through the
magic of makeup gave him a real rush
the sith lord's appearance instantly
communicates that he's a formidable
presence and a major menace
his unique look combined with park's
particular set of skills resulted in a
villain who truly terrified every star
wars fan in the world
during a 2019 interview with sci-fi wire
park recalled a directive he received
from producer rick mccallum
from rick it was like now rey i want you
to be mean i want you to scare every
child in america and around the world
you're gonna be bad this turned out to
be an inspired casting choice as park
was able to use his martial arts
background to battle in a lightsaber
fight grounded in very little script
direction
his face might not be recognizable in
this role but his moves definitely are
when dave chase isn't climbing out of
the tv as she did in the 2002 horror
classic the ring
she's a considerably less terrifying
figure in fact she's even worked as a
model her tv and movie parts have
definitely been on the darker side
though her first major live-action role
was the 2001 psychological thriller
donnie darko as the title character's
little sister
and then starting in 2006 she played the
sociopathic rhonda volmer on the hbo
series big love
in the ring chase played samara whose
fiendish powers have created a cursed
videotape that kills people seven days
after they've watched it while samara is
mostly seen with long black hair a
haggard face and a white gown
we do briefly get to see her without
ghoulish makeup in one scene
during a recording of a psychiatric
session watched by naomi watts character
samara discusses her inability to
control her psychic powers
chase was only 12 years old when the
film came out so you might not recognize
her nowadays if you see her on the
street both because she's probably not
wearing all that villain makeup
and because she's all grown up i'm sorry
it won't stop with his performance as
the joker in 2008's the dark knight the
late heath ledger gave the world perhaps
the most iconic portrayal of the clown
prince of crime
though he was rendered unrecognizable by
makeup stringy green hair
and a devilish sneer his name has become
synonymous with the role that's in large
part because ledger didn't just become
the joker when he put on the makeup his
commitment ran
much deeper than that throughout
production on the film he kept a diary
full of playing cards quotes from the
movie and excerpts from the comics that
reflect the neuroses of the character
he locked himself away in apartments and
hotel rooms to work on the diary
allowing himself to perfect his
portrayal of the terrifying criminal
see i'm not a monster
i'm just ahead of the curve underneath
the joker makeup ledger was a handsome
man with dirty blonde hair
he also had plenty of other talents and
hobbies besides acting
as he was both a former chess champion
and an avid photographer
his acting work ranged from the 1999
teen rom-com 10 things i hate about you
to wrenching dramas like 2005's
brokeback mountain the joker was just
one of his many triumphs on screen but
it's one that fans of his will always
remember with awe
the greatest mystery of rebecca remains
mystique who first appears on screen in
2000's x-men
is how her blue makeup was able to stick
to her it wasn't easy as her first
screen test required a jaw-dropping 12
hours in the makeup chair which was cut
down to a still staggering 9 for the
second movie
2003's x2 x-men united and finally down
to 7 for 2006's x-men the last stand
that all sounds particularly grueling
even by hollywood standards
in fact it seems like it would require
mutant powers for an actor to get
through it
especially when you consider that
romaine had to be made up and on set at
9am
as for the rest of her career she's had
plenty of other roles that don't require
quite so much detailed preparation
you may have seen her for example as
number one on star trek discovery or as
alexis mead on ugly betty and she's also
hosted skin wars a competition show that
centers around insane body painting
challenges
she certainly knows something about that
it's not just the bald head and the
missing nose that make ray finds so
unrecognizable as harry potter nemesis
lord voldemort it's also the fact that
the actor is rather striking in real
life and you don't have to look far for
proof
as he's appeared in a number of films in
which his natural face is fully visible
though voldemort's visage is decidedly
different from fines
the transformational process wasn't as
complicated as you might expect
temporary tattoos false teeth and fake
fingernails were all it took to turn
this talented thespian into the most
despised villain in the wizarding world
over in the muggle world you've probably
seen finds in a variety of flicks in
1993 he infamously played war criminal
ammun gert in schindler's list which
earned him an oscar nomination for best
supporting actor
then 1996's the english patient led to
another round of accolades and more
recently he's appeared in the likes of
clash of the titans the grand budapest
hotel and the james bond franchise
starting with 2012's skyfall check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one